et si la voiture est une certaine
vitesse était finalement nécessaire pour
entrer véritablement forêt de chaux pour
aller à la rencontre de son énergie pour
braver son incroyable puissance et être
à la hauteur de ses dimensions pour être
totalement conscient de passer d'un
monde à l'autre
après quelques minutes de route et
quelques années de connivence on peut
ainsi deviner son humeur du moment et se
préparer à s'y soumettre
alors seulement tout devient possible à
pied cette fois et des allemands mais il
faut d'abord en passer par là rouler un
peu avant de lui rendre visite avant de
choisir le voyage qu'on va faire avec
elle il y a une raison à cela la forêt
de chaux est beaucoup plus qu'une simple
forêt elle a traversé les siècles et
survécu à toutes les vicissitudes que
les hommes y ont imposé pour devenir au
fil du temps un être complexe et
résistant une sorte de personnage en
elle-même à la fois sujet et actrice
d'une très longue histoire
[Musique]
oh
jusqu'à l'horizon vingt-deux mille
hectares de chênes et de hêtres et de
charme
enchâssé entre la vallée du doubs et
celle de la loue forme le massif
forestier de chaud son origine est très
ancienne et remonte à des temps où la
nature n'était pas encore aux mains de
l'homme tout commence pour elle par une
curieuse anomalie un secret vieux de
plus de 4 millions d'années dont la
plaie est à la fois très proche de nuit
et très bien des simuler donc les
cailloutis de la forêt de chaux ceux par
qui tout est arrivé
c'est ça les voilà c'est une masse de
cailloutis enrobé dans du sable
on les voit ici sur deux trois mètres
légèrement et boulay mais ils sont
beaucoup plus profond c'est à dire qu'il
y a une cinquantaine voire une
soixantaine de mètres de ces cailloutis
on voit que les éléments sont arrondis
donc ça suppose qu'ils aient été traîné
dans un fleuve pendant de longs
kilomètres pour arrondir des choses
comme ça par ailleurs on ne voit pas de
calcaire là dedans ce qui est blanc ce
qui pourrait passer pour du calcaire
cela en fait une roche très dure c'est
du quartz ou des quartzites il ya des
vieux gréements tu es trés trés siliceux
qu'on voit aussi ce sont des galets qui
sont faits dans une roche de couleurs
assez grenat rouges sont connus très
bien c'est ses galets de radio larry
dans ces roches de radio la reid dans
les halles donc manifestement ces roches
cette accumulation de galets de sable
sont issus des alpes c'est cailloutis
ils arrivaient par un fleuve tumultueux
par un fleuve très gros accumulant cette
masse qui constitue le sous sol de la
forêt de chaux
le massif forestier de show est né de
cette géologie
en effet son sol et son sous sol de
cailloutis acides sont très pauvres peu
fertile et ils n'appellent quelconque
culture depuis la nuit des temps et
malgré quelques tentatives les hommes ne
se sont donc jamais donné la pelle y
entreprendre de défrichement il l'est
certes en place le milieu naturel
originel qui au fil des millénaires
allait devenir la forêt de chaux mais
outre la richesse qu'on représentait
très tôt son bois est également les
animaux et le gibier qu'elle abritait
cette forêt recèle d'autres trésors
issus également de la géologie dans les
hommes ont su très tôt tiré profit en
fait les alluvions côté du doubs sont
plutôt géré riche en argile et puis les
alluvions côté loups sont plutôt riche
conséquent sable siliceux alors nul
n'ignore que pour faire du verre on a
besoin de silice nom des sables riche en
silice forcément pour les verriers c'est
formidable et puis j'irai aussi bizarre
ça puisse paraître l'argile qu'on l'on
trouve du côté du tout ça intéressant
pour la verrie aussi plus qu'à cette
époque là les briques des fous on pour
faire des briques réfractaires sont
faites à partir de l'argile travaillé
par les potiers qui travaille pour la
vie donc en fait finalement tous les
éléments sont réunis localement en
termes je dirais de matériaux que l'on
trouve dans le sol
et puis encore une raison fondamentale
ont rejoint toujours l'énergie parce
qu'en fait il faut des torrents de bois
pensez bien que pour faire monter
une telle température plus que pour
faire fondre le vert il va falloir au
moins 1100 1200 degrés eh bien il est
clair qu'il faut des quantités pour
astronomique donc à cette époque à la
fois rétro et tout à fait idéal pour
installer des very puisque quand on est
vraiment à l'origine les verts y sont
itinérantes et court après le bois dans
une forêt comme la forêt de chaux elle a
plus besoin d'être itinérante et donc
elle s'installe à peu près à quatre
kilomètres du site de la ville loi c'est
ce qu'on appelle la vieille verrière et
là on est en 1190 excusez du peu vain
d'ailleurs une clairière à l'heure
actuelle permet encore de situer à peu
près son implantation à peu près à 2 300
mètres de la ligne de chemin de fer
à partir du xviiie siècle les verreries
seront suivis peu à peu par de nouvelles
industries plus avides encore en bois et
en énergie et qui comme elle
s'installèrent en lisière de la forêt de
chaux il ya un enjeu considérable
c'est en fait les forges l'industrie
métallurgique c'est les emplois de
marines et les canons c'est les boules
est donc on sent bien quelque part qu'il
ya un besoin considérable de bois si on
prend les forges de fraisans sec 58
militaires les forges de rance est allé
15 à 20 mystère c'est quelque chose
d'important
la saline d'arc-et-senans consommera en
seize militaires mais la verrie david
loix consomme 15 mystère on peut parler
d'une dimension stratégique du bois
avant dans un premier temps bien entendu
on est dans une époque très guerrière on
peut admettre que les besoins militaires
c'est quelque chose de considérable mais
aussi tout aussi stratégique mais pour
les habitants le besoin au bois de
chauffage une ville de dole ses 18
ministères les villages riverains autour
de la forêt de choses ces 44 mystère
c'est quelque chose de considérable à
l'époque c'est la seule énergie que l'on
utilisé encore
à la même époque le trésor d'énergie que
représentait cette forêt acquerra elle
de façon très originale une autre
industrie grande consommatrice de bois
installée dès le xiiie siècle les
salines de salins les bains avait en
effet consommé au fil du temps tous les
bois des alentours de cette ville pour
chauffer les normes bassin à son mieux
dont était extrait par évaporation le
sel puiser dans le sous sol
il a donc fallu trouver une autre source
d'approvisionnement en énergie ainsi fut
décidé la construction en 1774 en
bordure de la forêt de chaux de la seule
ligne royale d'arc et senans la saumure
venait toujours de salins acheminés sur
plus de 20 kilomètres par un somme au
duc fait de tuyaux en bois il était en
effet techniquement plus facile de
transporter l'eau salée à arc-et-senans
que d'acheminer à salins les quantités
astronomiques de bois nécessaires à son
évaporation confié à l'esprit
visionnaire de l'architecte claude
nicolas ledoux la saline royale d'arc et
senans fut véritablement adossé à la
lisière du massif de chaud ce qui lui
assurait un approvisionnement en bois à
la fois régulier et pérenne à l'apogée
de l'exploitation de la saline royale
des forges et de la verrerie
ce sont donc au minimum 200 milles
stères de bois qui étaient prélevés
chaque année en forêt de chaux
aujourd'hui ceci représente la quantité
nécessaire au chauffage de dix à douze
mille foyers utilisant cette source
d'énergie
voir
[Musique]
mais d'où vient l'énergie du poids d'où
vient ce pouvoir calorifique utilisé
depuis la nuit des temps et dont la
maîtrise a soumis l'entrée de l'espèce
humaine dans sa modernité tout
simplement d'un phénomène extraordinaire
la photosynthèse
elle se reproduit de façon immuable tous
les ans dès le début du printemps
lorsque les premières feuilles se
déploient les moteurs essentiels de
cette formidable machinerie biologique
sans la chlorophylle et le soleil dans
chacune des millions de cellules de
chaque feuille de chaque arbre la
chlorophylle accompli chaque jour son
miracle permanent grâce à l'énergie
solaire le gaz carbonique de l'air est
séparé en oxygène et en carbone
au fil des années celui-ci se stockent
dans les troncs et des branches des
arbres sous forme de cellulose autrement
dit de bois ainsi pour fabriquer un
kilogramme de ce matériau les feuilles
d'un arbre adulte ont dû traiter durant
son existence plus de 4000 mètres cube
d'air un arbre adulte en pleine maturité
et donc l'ensemble des forêts
représentent d'une certaine façon de
l'énergie solaire stockée sous forme de
poids
[Musique]
les salines les verreries et les
poteries installés autour de la forêt de
chaux étaient de grandes consommatrices
de cette énergie
mais les forges avait besoin de plus
encore dans n'utiliser la quintessence
la part essentielle qu'est le charbon de
bois
alors pourquoi du charbon de bois bête
tout simplement parce que on s'est vite
aperçu contre le bois naturel celui que
l'on couple l'hiver et entre le charbon
que l'on va en tirer et bien il y a une
différence énergétique la fabrication du
charbon de bois qu'est ce que c'est
c'est tout simplement le fait d'extraire
du bois toute l'eau constitutionnel de
ne plus avoir de fumée et de ne
conserver que le carbone qui va nous
produire une chaleur intense
alors comment est ce qu on le fabrique
comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir extraire
cette eau constitutionnel et bien
différentes techniques seront adaptés à
travers le monde à travers les périodes
à travers les peuples qu'ils vont
développer différentes formes de
fabrication nous en europe on va en
développer une très performant qui va
nous permettre d'obtenir du charbon qui
va approcher les 90% de carbone alors le
charbon se fabriquer à l'aide de menus
boirin qu'on appelle de la charbonnet qu
on entend déjà le mot charbon dans ces
petits morceaux de bois qui vont être
coupés en morceaux de 66 cm de long deux
fois le pied du roi et semoy va être
dressé c'est à dire que l'on va sur une
place de quart no nisation bien plat de
biens propres circulaire en faire une
couche de couches on va constituer ce
qu'on appelle une meule par le meule de
foin on parle meules de comté on va
parler de meules de charbonnier
une fois que cette meule est constituée
on va pas y est la même c'est à dire que
l'on va ramasser des feuilles dans la
forêt et on va donc que mettre cette
couche protectrice sur le bois de
manière que la terre que l'on va mettre
dessus et bien ne s'infiltre pas entre
les morceaux de bois on va pouvoir
monter sur cette meule et introduire le
feu à l'intérieur
une fois que le feu aura embrasé le
centre de notre mail on va fermer la
cheminée ensuite ce sera une conduite
une conduite pendant quatre cinq jours
car il va falloir surveiller toute cette
évolution de manière que la combustion
soit homogène que ça carbonise pas plus
d'un côté que de l'autre
et une fois que la meule soir froid dit
nous viendrons crever la meule comme on
dit c'est à dire tirer le charbon en
écartant cette terre protectrice qui a
permis donc cette carbonisation 100 m
car tout le secret là et donc obtention
d'un charbon vraiment de très très très
grande qualité
la fabrication et la production de cet
or noir de l'époque étaient aux mains de
la corporation des charbonniers seule
leur savoir faire ancestral et est à
même de fournir en quantité suffisante
le précieux combustible capables de
générer la puissance de chauffe
nécessaires à la fabrication de la fonte
et des as et dans mes hauts fourneaux à
l'apogée de l'utilisation du charbon de
bois au 19e siècle la population de
charbonnier de la forêt de chaux à
thèmes les plus de 500 personnes qui
vivaient en permanence en forêt dans des
habitats rudimentaire dès le milieu du
xixème siècle l'arrivée progressive du
charbon de terre de la houille sonnera
l'abandon progressif de l'utilisation du
charbon de bois et la disparition du
métier de charbonnier peu à peu la forêt
de chaux perdra son rôle central de
fournisseuses d'énergie industrielles
pour ne subvenir aux besoins domestiques
et de bois d'oeuvre comme dans le
lointain passé
heureusement d'ailleurs car les
prélèvements énorme qu'on y avait
pratiqué pendant des décennies l'avait
plus d'une fois mise à mal
de ce passé tumultueux et actif reste
des témoignages bien visible dans les
paysages de la forêt de chaux à partir
de colbert et pendant deux siècles
d'exploitation intense et gestionnaires
successifs de la forêt de chaux en avait
organisé l'accès afin d'extraire les
bois avec le maximum d'efficacité des
chemins forestiers et des chaumières
quadrillaient toute l'étendue du massif
et permettait un accès aisé aux
profondeurs des parcelles les plus
éloignés ils sont toujours en vigueur de
nos jours sans que l'on se doute
véritablement de leur origine qui sait
par exemple en empruntant la route
forestière de grands contours que le
tracé de celle ci date de 1781 environ
sur cette route qui traverse la forêt de
chaux quasiment de part en part
les sept colom qui marque les
croisements avec les saules hier date de
ce passé lointain
à l'origine elle permettait aux
utilisateurs de la forêt de se repérer
dans l'immensité du massif grâce au nom
des villages vers lesquelles chacune des
faces de leur chapiteau était tournée
elles sont devenues un des symboles les
plus forts de la forêt de chaux moderne
aujourd'hui même ses plus fidèles
habitués sont heureux de retrouver leur
présence familière pour s'est orientée
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à partir du début du xxème siècle
jusqu'à nos jours la forêt de chaux
retrouvera durant des décennies son rôle
ancien est primordial de productrice de
bois bois de chauffage pour la charpente
et pour la fabrication de traverses de
chemin de fer en 1964 la très ancienne
administration des eaux et forêts qui
assurait la gestion des forêts royales
et domanial française depuis le xviie
siècle se transforma en une nouvelle
entité appelée office national des
forêts dans la continuité du passé l'eau
nf poursuite en forêt de chaux la
mission ancestrale de mise en valeur du
patrimoine forestier
mais comme d'autres cette forêt est
devenu aujourd'hui bien plus qu'un
simple lieu de production de bois la
forêt de chaux comme l'ensemble des
forêts publiques françaises bénéficient
d'une gestion multifonctionnelle alors
la gestion multifonctionnelle repose
globalement sur trois socles un des
premiers socle la production forestière
c'est à dire la mobilisation des bois
les bois que l'on récolte les bois qui
sont mis en marché et ses bois mis en
marché vont permettre à un tissu
d'entreprises aussi bien du bûcheron du
débardeur d'avoir une activité
économique local
cet aspect production est quelque chose
de très important au niveau de la
filière et génère bien entendu des
recettes pour les propriétaires soit
pour le nf en forêt domaniale ou pour
les communes en forêt communale
[Musique]
le deuxième point c'est le socle de la
protection et de la préservation des
espaces naturels des espèces
relativement sensibles
donc ça au travers soi de mesures de
protection que sont les réserves
biologiques
on en a deux en forêt de chaux une
réserve biologique intégrale
on ne fera rien c'est une règle de
gestion n'ont rien faire à partir du
moment où ses écrits et ses actes et
dans le document on va laisser les
arbres vieillir jusqu'au stade ultime
mourir de leur belle mort rester sur
place des composés etc
on a eu notre réserve biologique est une
réserve biologique dirigée ou la gestion
est dirigé vers la préservation et le
maintien des écosystèmes intéressant en
place et en l'occurrence pour la forêt
de chaux dans la réserve biologique
dirigée de la clause l'écosystème
intéressant c'est les aulnes et
alluviales résiduelles enfin le
troisième socle de gestion c'est la
fonction sociale de la forêt il faudrait
aménager donc on participe à
l'aménagement du territoire
on doit répondre dans la mesure du
possible aux aspirations donc de nos
concitoyens dans l'aspect loisir en
ouvrant la forêt dans le respect de la
réglementation en place
bien entendu ce n'est pas parce que la
forêt est ouverte au public on doit
aller partout et n'importe comment en
véhiculant vélo en moto etc
donc il ya des règles à respecter si par
le passé la prise en compte de ces trois
éléments se faisait naturellement
globalement on le faisait un peu sans le
savoir voilà maintenant c'est vraiment
ancrée de manière
très clair dans nous dans notre doctrine
en fait on alterne en permanence avec
ces trois fonctions de la forêt que sont
la production la protection et la
fonction sociale espaces naturels
quelque peu hors norme par ses
dimensions et son grand intérêt
biologique et écologique la forêt de
chaux fait depuis quelques années
l'objet d'un statut particulier
comme d'autres sites de franche comté la
forêt de chaux est aussi un site natura
2000 le classement natura 2000 n'est pas
un statut de réserve et il ne s'agit pas
de mettre la forêt sous cloche en fait
simplement avec des choix de gestion et
des bonnes pratiques
on va tenter de préserver la
biodiversité tout en maintenant les
activités alors en forêt on va trouver
une mosaïque d'habitats forestiers en
majorité ici surtout la hêtraie on
mélange avec des chaînes donc la qualité
écologique c'est les vieux arbres des
arbres avec les cavités c'est les
peuplements qui sont mélangés
c'est donc une diversité d'arbres et de
milieu mais en forêt on va aussi avoir
des habitats qui sont très particuliers
comme ici la clause on a aussi les
douleurs sont des petites rivières
forestière puisqu'entre excité avec une
végétation assez naturelle des zones des
frênes et puis une qualité d'eau qui est
assez assez bonne inde et au cur donc
natura 2000 ici va viser conserver la
qualité écologique voire la restaurer
dans certains cas si les sites ne sont
plus trop favorable à la vie la forêt de
chaux est classée natura de lille
également du fait de sa taille
en effet dans une très grande forêt
peuvent s'installer de population
d'année nous à la recherche de grands
espaces de tranquillité leur offrant à
la fois logique et le couvert dont ils
ont besoin
outre les cervidés on y soupçonne par
exemple la présence de la très discrète
si l'un noir
les pics sont également très attiré par
cette vaste superficie boisée six
espèces différentes niches temps forêt
de chaux et ils sont parmi les premiers
à animer les sous bois à la sortie de
l'hiver le tambour images des pics est
une sorte de chant qui permet à ces
oiseaux de délimiter leur territoire
chaque espèce a son propre rythme sa
durée et sa fréquence particulière qui
parle uniquement à ses congénères
la sonorité dépend seulement du support
sur lequel fera pas mal
avec le clic laisser ma forêt des arbres
et des hommes pour plonger véritablement
de l'autre côté du décor à la rencontre
d'une tout autre forêt celle de ceux qui
ont choisi d'y vivre ce zoo celle qui
compte finalement pour si peu coûteux
car celle là une pince hull et graves
problèmes elle ou du moins leurs pattes
se retrouvent chaque année à la carte de
nombreux restaurants des alentours de la
forêt ou dans l'assiette de quelques
amateurs
ramassage trop facile et sans gloire
lorsque les grenouilles rousses viennent
se reproduire par milliers sur leur
habituelle place de froch l'orgie
reproductrices dure plusieurs jours
intenses frénétique ininterrompue les
mâles s'empressant de saisir chaque
nouvelle femelle arrivant sur le site de
reproduction
tout cela resterait dans l'ordre des
choses si leur ardeur et leur
empressement de lait faisait pas se
jeter véritablement sur tout ce qui
bouge autour d'eux les salamandres
terrestre qui viennent souvent pondre à
la même époque dans les mares forestière
concept quelque chose d'ailleurs très
régulièrement elles ne survivent pas à
ces assauts absurde qui les maintiennent
trop longtemps sous l'eau
avec la ferai des grenouilles rousses
le signal est donné elle ne se trompe
jamais les verts ne reviendra plus et la
machine de la vie sera mais une fois de
plus en route un des trésors cachés de
l'autre monde de la forêt de chaux n'est
pas très loin des parts s2 nivéales rien
de particulier au premier abord les
ennuyer ghz et ne tardera pas à
découvrir un curieux détails voici le
coeur de l'une des neuf sources du
ruisseau des douleurs celles ci ne sont
pas tout à fait comme les autres à
travers le sable du fonds l'on sort en
effet directement d'une des nappes
phréatiques souterraines de la forêt de
chaux avec un volume et une température
froide d'une très grande régularité
l'eau extrêmement pur qui l'alimentent
fait de ce ruisseau une véritable
exception à une époque où les milieux
aquatiques en bon état biologique se
font de plus en plus rares il est un des
derniers refuges d'espèces animales très
sensible aux pollutions de toutes sortes
côté poisson c'est par exemple un
paradis pour les chabot l'animal est
extrêmement discret il ne quitte jamais
l'abri des galets où il sait
parfaitement se dissimuler l'étrange
coloration rouge ou vert vif des galets
des douleurs est une autre originalité
de ce ruisseau pas tout à fait comme les
autres elle est dû semble-t-il à des
algues microscopiques qui se développe
spécifiquement à leur surface
changement de décor à la rencontre de la
clau le second ruisseau emblématique de
la forêt de chaux ici depuis la nuit des
temps
d'autres amateurs d'eau de qualité
perpétue un très étrange rituel après
cinq ou six années d'existence larvaires
dans le lit du ruisseau les lamproies de
planaire sont sortis du sable pour
quelques semaines de vie adulte
consacrer exclusivement à la
reproduction
le jeu consiste à choisir un emplacement
puis a enlevé les petits galets du fond
pour atteindre le sable sur lequel les
femelles déposeront leur zone elles sont
incapables de se nourrir et n'utilisent
leur bouche en forme devant tout ce que
pour ce curieux manège
chacun de ces étranges animaux très
primitif disparaîtra peu de temps après
la pente en ayant ainsi achevé son cycle
de vie
d'autres espèces animales trouve dans
les ruisseaux de la forêt de chaux un
milieu à la hauteur de leurs exigences
certains insectes parmi les tricks
optèrent par exemple ne se rencontrent
ici ou dans de rares endroits en franche
comté
certes ils sont affaires de spécialiste
mais constitue une richesse biologique à
protéger à tout prix les berges creuse
les galets et les amas de bois morts
immergés des douleurs née de la clause
ont longtemps abrité une autre rareté
l'écrevisse indigènes ap les écrevisses
à pattes blanches
[Musique]
actuellement seule une très petite
population de cette espèce extrêmement
sensible à la qualité de l'eau survie en
forêt de chaux où elles font l'objet
d'une attention constante
[Musique]
tout au long de leur parcours les
ruisseaux de la forêt de chaux et leurs
petites vallées alluviales offre
également l'occasion d'entrer dans un
tout autre univers que celui de la forêt
habituel sur ses sols gorgés d'eau les
halls ne sont rois ce sont des arbres
sans grande valeur que l'homme
l'exploitent plus depuis longtemps
la plupart du temps le milieu s'est donc
développée plus ou moins à sa guise à
l'intérieur ou en dehors des réserves
naturelles mise en place récemment
ici la nature a gardé l'essentiel de ses
droits à qui veut bien sortir des
saulnières et des sentiers battus de la
forêt de chaux elle propose un voyage
vers d'autres sensations dans un univers
aux allures de jungle miniature quelques
plantes d'apparence anodine cachent leur
rareté dans cette luxuriance inattendue
elles ont pour nom grands de ce monde où
baldin gère par exemple et participe
avec d'autres espèces à la richesse de
la biodiversité discrète de la forêt de
chaux
[Musique]
il
mais la magie de ces lieux prendra toute
sa dimension beaucoup plus tard dans la
journée
il suffit pour cela d'un peu de patience
de savoir se laisser aller pour être
capable de s'y laisser prendre
et bien sûr de ne pas avoir peur du noir
[Musique]
oh
racine maléfique des hommes ceux des
contes et des légendes arbres ou au bois
rouge doté de propriétés magiques arbres
des démons des sorcières et des mauvais
génie dont seul le lever du jour est
capable de chasser les maléfices de nos
esprits peu à peu ensorcelé
[Musique]
apaisement de la lumière retrouver pour
un retour aux réalités de l'envers du
décor mais sans encore véritablement
quitté los de la forêt de chaux voilà
une bestiole dans la réputation dépasse
très largement la taille et la beauté
diront certains pour ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas encore voici le fameux
crapaud sonneur fameux car la forêt de
cheveux abrite une population importante
de ce petit batracien
à l'heure où au plan national il est en
régression constante comme bien d'autres
espèces sa petite personne a donc droit
à une attention particulière de la part
des différents gestionnaires des massifs
forestiers de champ hors de la forêt
proprement dite les talus des routes et
des sommières offre d'autres milieux de
vie relativement stable et tranquille
qui font le bonheur de quelques espèces
plutôt discrète
si madame saluant brin monsieur a des
élégantes un peu plus voyante mais
quelle que soit de costumes tous les
deux savent parfaitement se dissimuler
dans la brousse de leur petit territoire
pour les lézards agile aussi en forêt de
chaux est un refuge
à l'heure où partout ailleurs leurs
populations sont menacés par l'activité
humaine
elise y côtoie de temps à autre la
couleuvre à collier autres reptiles
devenu par contre relativement commun au
fil du temps dans le massif
[Musique]
celui là de son côté se faire / les
amateurs d'insectes
leucan de son état il ne se rencontrent
que dans un secteur extrêmement limité à
l'est de la forêt de chaux ou sa
population est très peu abondantes
les mâles sont reconnaissables à la
taille démesurée de leurs mandibules
dont il se sert parfois lors
d'affrontements avec leurs congénères en
période de reproduction
[Musique]
quant à l'esprit animal de la forêt de
chaux si l'on accepte de mettre de côté
les serres peut-être faut-il le trouver
au frais d'un autre symbole celui de
l'âme tellurique des blaireaux ils sont
à peu près partout chez eux ici
repérable par leurs terriers mais très
discret par leur comportement presque
toujours nocturne
seul le moment de l'élevage des jeunes
impatients de quitter leur trou les
pousse à sortir avant la nuit tombée
l'agitation du petit monde de l'envers
du décor de la forêt de chaux s'apaisent
au milieu de l'été une fois toutes les
parades accompli toutes les progénitures
élevé est définitivement parti mener
leur propre existence
la forêt s'installe alors dans un autre
temps plus lent plus silencieux jusqu'à
la surprise d'une première fraîcheur
matinale annonciatrice pour les initiés
d'une possibilité toujours très attendu
[Musique]
qui saura jamais comment qui sera jamais
pourquoi un jour un premier jour de fin
août ou début septembre
le premier d'entre eux est là comme
chaque année au même endroit ou presque
venu de nulle part
ce
les autres ne sont pas loin les solistes
s'installe les acteurs prennent leur
place
rien ne presse
ce
il faut encore auxerre laisser le décor
s'installer l'essai se poser la lumière
idéal laisser quelques menues chanteur m
en humeur le spectateur et le faire
patienter encore un peu avant
l'ouverture réelle du concert
[Musique]
durant la période la plus pleine de son
déroulement
le brame des cerfs dollar parfois avant
la tombée du jour mais il n'atteint sa
véritable puissance qu'une fois la nuit
installée
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il en faut plus pour perturber la vie
nocturne de la forêt où chacun suit ses
petites habitudes sans se préoccuper des
folies sonore dessert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'opéra forestier durera toute l'année
avec ses ténors c'est paroxysme et c'est
épuisement ce coeur serré citant s'est
calmé ces volupté qui pousseront les
plus endurants a continué leur joute ce
moment bien au delà de l'aube
[Musique]
depuis leur introduction au milieu des
années 50 et au fil des décennies les
serres sont devenus inséparables de la
forêt de chaux ils ont apporté une part
de magie supplémentaire de sensations
primitive et esthétique puissante de
liens réels ou peut être simplement
rêver avec ses treize anciennes régions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
éternel indifférence apparente des
biches et qui pourtant toute cette
énergie séductrice et finalement
destinées du moins le croit teint car
quand est il vraiment du rôle exact du
chant des mâles dans une préférence pour
l'un ou l'autre d'entre eux
si le mot préférence à véritablement un
sens dans le monde animal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au milieu de la matinée les derniers
brahms et puise avec la lente montée du
soleil chaque protagoniste quitte sa
place de chant pour regagner une
cachette discrète où il passera la
journée au repos avant de reprendre son
rôle dans le concert des le soir venu
le manège durera ainsi plusieurs
semaines
qui peut rester insensible aux
spectacles offerts chaque automne par
les serres leur présence en forêt
magique pour les uns mais elle est
beaucoup moins si l'on se glisse dans
l'oeil du forestier on ne tardera pas à
l'heure à découvrir une autre facette de
leur existence avec des jeunes plants de
m et surtout de chêne brouter parleurs
dans les cervidés cerfs chevreuils
consomment de la végétation la strate
herbacée les graminées des semis mieux
la ronce ou des jeunes pousses de plants
forestiers alors l'expansion de manière
trop importante des populations de
cervidés ou leur concentration excessive
est de nature à compromettre en fait la
bio diversité de la flore forestière et
notamment cette pression cette
consommation par les cervidés et de
nature à perturber le mélange des
essences forestières et cela peut aller
jusqu'à une disparition de l'essence
forestière qui nous intéresse et on se
retrouve avec un peuplement
on avait réussi à mener de manière on va
dire naturel à partir du moment où
l'équilibré rompu on perd ces jeunes ce
nul au profit soit 2 être des choses
comme ça de charme qui ne sont pas
forcément les essences adaptées aux sols
et les essences que l'on veut nous
cultiver partant de là si on n'a pas de
jeunes pousses en quantité suffisante
nous sommes contraints de repartir à
zéro malheureusement et là qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va planter
on va faire venir des plans élevé en
pépinière d'accord hélas à partir du
moment où mais c'est blanc en place nous
sommes contraints de les protéger avec
des réflexions lourde qui est le
grillage de deux mètres de haut qui
serra
maintenir l'origine du gibier en place
et là en l'occurrence et pour éviter aux
serres de rentrer dans ces jeunes
peuplements qui sont le renouvellement
les futurs forêt qui feront dans 150 ans
les produits que nous recherchons
utilisé de façon occasionnelle en forêt
de chaux sur des parcelles au sol peu
favorable cette méthode heurtant le
regard mais très rationnel de gestion
forestière tend à remplacer
historiquement l'ancienne pratique du
taï issouf 8es elle est destinée à
obtenir à terme une forêt peuplée d'une
seule espèce d'arbre du même âge plus
facile à conduire et à exploiter dans
l'avenir par les nouveaux moyens
mécaniques
malgré les apparences de vide
la relève est donc en place sous forme
de jeunes plants mais il faudra attendre
plusieurs dizaines d'années avant que la
forêt ne retrouve son aspect habituel
cependant ce passage au régime de la
futaie régulière est parfois remise en
cause qu ils présentent certains
inconvénients
hormis les dégâts sur les jeunes plants
provoquée par les cervidés dans sa phase
initiale
il provoque à l'abattage des semenciers
une brusque perturbation de l'écosystème
forestier et de ses paysages
il induit également des risques de
modification des sols et présente un
bilan économique globale que d'aucuns
considèrent parfois comme un certain sur
le long terme
bien entendu d'autres méthodes de
gestion existe pratiquée dès l'origine
de la sylviculture tels que la futaie
jardinée ou le taï issouf uteq
elle consiste à l'opposé à élevé sur une
même parcelle des arbres d'âge de taille
et parfois des sens très différents dans
ce cas la récolte des arbres arrivé à
maturité
bouleversé beaucoup moins le milieu
forestier taillis chutait et futaie
jardinée offre enfin et ce n'est pas la
moindre des choses
un paysage tout à fait différent plus
conforme aux aspirations esthétique de
beaucoup d'amoureux de la forêt
amélioration de la productivité contre
approche plus écologique
le débat est vaste et complexe mais
risque peut-être de se clore dans les
années à venir car si la mécanisation de
l'exploitation forestière est ancienne
l'apparition de nouveaux outils laisse
présager des évolutions radicales
nous avons tous de ce type à
l'efficacité redoutable font maintenant
peu un peu partie du paysage forestier
en franche comté
elles vont de pair ou commence à
répondre à des évolutions importantes du
travail en forêt et de la demande en
bois sa traduction en est de plus en
plus visible au bord des routes et des
saulières de la forêt de chaux
outre les grumes habituel le bois
résineux destiné à la pâte à papier et
les interminables piles de bois destinés
au chauffage domestique un autre type de
stockage est apparue depuis quelques
années ses allures moins régulière et
les quantités impressionnantes mise en
bord de route peuvent cintrier de
passants et si la forêt énergie
d'autrefois étaient en train de faire
son retour
c'est bien le cas en fait car une partie
de la production forestière s'oriente
maintenant vers un nouveau marché en
plein développement celui de l'énergie
bois toute cette matière brute y compris
des branches d'un diamètre respectable
est destiné à être déchiquetés
transformer en plaquettes de bois puis
brûlé dans de grandes unités de
production d'énergie à usage urbain
une chaufferie bois comme celle de
besançon d'une puissance de 6 mégawatts
autrement dit 2 6 millions de watts par
heure en consomment plus de 12000 tonnes
par an soit plus de 30 tonnes par jour
en moyenne plus de 400 chaufferie
industrielle au collectif de ce type
sont en activité en franche-comté
consommant actuellement 150 mille tonnes
de bois-énergie par an
la production forestière locale à
laquelle participe largement la forêt de
chaux est capable de subvenir aux
besoins mais avec une prévision de
croissance de plus de 10% par an les
limites ne seront elles pas rapidement
atteintes
d'autre part ce nouveau débouché
économique risque peut-être de
bouleverser les équilibres en place au
détriment des utilisations plus
classiques comme le bois d'oeuvre ou la
fois l'énergie bois suscite par ailleurs
d'autres interrogations liées par
exemple au renouvellement très lent de
la ressource à l'impact encore mal
évalués sur la pérennité des sols
forestiers ou à la faible prise en
compte des volumes importants
transportés par la route mais d'autres
questionnement s'ajoute à cela sur le
long terme pour la forêt de chaux posée
par exemple par les évolutions
climatiques qui se dessine un des sujets
qu'il n'ont qu'ils occuperont pour la
forêt chaussée les ce qu'on nous annonce
en termes de changements donc climatique
est bien entendu au niveau des essences
forestières à à renouveler et à éduquer
c'est un enjeu très important il faut
savoir qu'en forêt de chaux le chêne et
l'essence majoritaire peu près 60% de
recouvrement après c'est le hêtre et si
on nous annonce donc un changement
climatique réchauffement des
températures canicules il est clair que
le hêtre aura de moins en moins sa place
dans le paysage de la forêt de chaux
donc on aura tendance à voir une forêt
qui va s'enrichir progressivement en
chaîne et il y a une autre essences
résineuses qui a tout à fait sa place
qui est le pin sylvestre qui se
développe très bien en forêt de chaux et
le pin sylvestre et en essence frugale a
toute sa place sur ces milieux
face à ces perspectives comment se
dessine l'avenir de la forêt de chaux
car elle est bien plus qu'un simple
regroupement d'arbres depuis des
millénaires comme les autres forêts elle
a été l'ennemi des hommes celle qui
abritait fauves les brigands celle
contre laquelle ils ont dû se battre
pour cultiver la terre mais elle a
également été généreuse en énergie en
matériaux et en nourriture de toutes
sortes stimulant leur imaginaire
alimentant leur compte et leurs légendes
la forêt est à tout jamais une fabuleuse
source d'émotion à la fois terrifiante
et enchanteresse
son mystère reste insondable et la
fascination qu'elle exerce sur l'homme
toujours aussi forte
nous
alors entre gains de productivité enjeux
énergétiques environnementaux sociaux ou
esthétique que va devenir la forêt de
champ les hommes l'obligeront il se
plier une nouvelle fois à leurs
exigences comme dans les siècles passés
ou bien parviendront-ils à trouver la
voix lui permettant de poursuivre sa
grande histoire dans laquelle sa magie
se mêlera encore à son volant c'est
strahl de fournisseurs de bois et
d'énergie
[Musique]
on
on prend
[Musique]
oh
bon
non
[Musique]
oh